[Funny Music]
Narration: Better data makes better decisions
From improved interaction to increased profits.
The Google Play Developer Console can help you
And Google Analytics in converting your app data
To practical statistics.
Here are ten things to measure
Which will help you create more successful applications
And in marketing them better.
It gives you a user acquisition performance report in the Developer Console
See how many users are visiting your app's listing in the store
And install your application.
You can also see the sources from which they came
Whether they are paid or free.
The Acquisition report also includes buyer data
So you can identify users who want to make purchases
In your app.
You'll know where the most important users come from
You'll be able to determine the impact factors for each channel in user installs for your apps
So you know better what points you should focus on.
In financial reports in the Developer Console
You can see the average revenue for each paying user
And learn how to monetize.
You can try making changes to your app
And see how these changes affect the value of your app.
You can also review the data
Which helps you to see how user spending patterns change
In your app over time.
The metrics we have talked about so far are fully available at
Developer Console.
When using the Google Analytics service in your app
Link them to the developer console,
You'll see a huge amount of valuable data
You can also analyze and use them
To discover useful information such as ...
User retention rates are a great indicator
About how well your app performs in the long run
Reports on active users in Google Analytics
How your active users continue to use your app
You can then think more about
How to keep users using the template reports.
And when selecting which users have stopped using your app
You can develop plans to change this phenomenon
From app improvements to automatic notifications
And app reuse ads.
It will give you the average duration of user sessions for the app
An idea of ​​how attractive your app is.
An increase in the duration of meetings may be indicated
More users interact with your app
And they get more benefit when you spend time using it.
You can then compare this data
As users return to use your app.
You may notice that they return frequently but for short periods
Or they use your app once per period but the usage time is great.
You can now experiment and measure the impact of application changes
In the pattern of user visits to your app.
You can see the Behavior Flow report in Google Analytics
Monitors often visited by users
And how they move from screen to screen within your app
You can use this data to optimize the task paths in
Experiment users with your app and improve this experience.
Often, users will need to do certain things,
Starting with subscribing to a service
To an in-app purchase process, for example.
These are your conversions.
Google Analytics lets you identify events
And the conversions you want to track.
And to know the success of each event
Increase the number of conversions
You can direct users to events that have been admired by many.
If your app sells actual products or services
Google Analytics can help you better understand your sales traffic.
Ecommerce and e-commerce reports help you
Know what products users buy
The average volume of applications
And how long it takes users to complete their purchases.
Analytics lets you track permanent value
For user transactions across your app
Through each marketing channel to gain users.
It lets you know which channels you bring
You are the most important users
You can adjust your marketing expenses accordingly.
Using the amount you earn
Throughout the duration of user activity in your app,
You can subtract what you spend on each user
Calculate your return on investment.
Of the collected data is anonymous,
You can identify different technological dimensions
For users, including the devices they use
And common screen sizes
And the version of the operating system they are using.
This will help improve the design of your app
And test your app with the appropriate device configurations.
The Developer Console and Google Analytics provide you
Data as well as means to analyze this data
So you can get a good idea of ​​how well your business is performing.
To increase your knowledge and identify
All the basics of Google Analytics,
You can sign up for the interactive course from the Analytics Academy
About Mobile App Analytics.
If you want more tips on how to improve the performance of your app
Or game and create a better app business
Check out other videos in this series
Download the "Google Play App Success Secrets" guide.